[SWOOSHING]
GUS CLASS: Hello, Google+
Developers.
I'm Gus Class, and I'm on
developer relations for the
Google+ team.
And today, we're going to be
talking about the Python
quick-start.
And so naturally, we brought in
one of our Python experts
from the Drive team,
Ali Afshar.
ALI AFSHAR: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
GUS CLASS: So a little trivia
about Ali is he
wrote his own IDE.
ALI AFSHAR: So I wrote
two IDEs actually.
They're great if you want
to check them out.
One of them's called PIDA, one
of them's called Abominade.
They're both written in Python,
and you can like them
if you like Vim.
GUS CLASS: There you go.
Well, it's great to have
you here, Ali.
And so let's get to the
quick-start video that we've
been working on this week.
And so we're going to just take
a quick look at it, and
it's a screen cast that we did
to show you how quick it is.
The instructions for the
Python quick-start are
available on developers.googl
e.com/+/quickstart/python.
The first step in the
instructions is to enable the
Google+ API.
This is what you do before
starting any project.
Navigate to
code.google.com/apis/console.
When you're here, create
a new project.
And then give your project
a title for you.
After you create the project,
you'll be redirected to the
services pane.
Inside of the services pane,
you'll need to turn on the
Google+ API.
After turning on the Google+
API, create a client ID and
client secret by navigating
to API Access.
The information that you enter
into this first window will be
customer facing, so
carefully pick it.
Next, set the authorized
JavaScript origin to local
host port 4567, as configured
in the sample.
Also, set the protocol
to HTTP.
After you've created your client
ID and client secret,
you're ready to clone
the project.
Run the git clone command to
clone the Python quick-start
from GitHub.
Next, set up Python as
you would do for any
other Python project.
And so I'll just use Virtual
Environment.
Next, go into the project
folder, and then install all
of the Python requirements by
running pip install dash r
requirements.txt.
After the requirements are
installed, you're ready to set
the client ID and client secret
in clientsecrets.JSON.
Copy and paste the client ID
from the API console project
you created, and copy the client
secret from the API
console project.
After you've put the client ID
and client secret in, you're
ready to run the sample.
Just run Python signin.py
to start the sample.
You'll be prompted for turning
on the web server, so just
make sure that you approve it.
And then navigate in a web
browser to local host port
4567, authorize the
application, and
you will see it run.
You've now run the Python
quick-start.
So that's it.
That's how long it takes to
run through the Python
quick-start.
And we timed me, and it
took me just about
two and a half minutes.
So it's really easy to do,
and you can see it going
right out the gate.
But you're probably asking, what
are the next things you
can do with the Python
quick-start?
And so some of the things that
we thought about doing were
deploying it to a cloud hosted
service, such as
Heroku or App Engine.
Ali, are there any changes that
would have to be made
inside of the quick-start
sample, in order to be capable
of deploying it to
these solutions?
ALI AFSHAR: So this is what
I really like about your
quick-start sample is
that you use a web
framework called Flask.
It's very close to my heart,
written by a number of people
I know and I've contributed
to.
It's a very light framework.
It's very easy to use.
And of course, with Python, as
with any Python web framework,
it's built on WSGI, the web
server gateway interface that
is this common infrastructure
for web applications to talk
to web servers.
So really, no, you can just dump
that thing anywhere you
like, and it will run.
So it will run on App Engine.
App Engine supports WSGI.
It will run on Heroku.
It will run on just about any
way you can host files.
If you just have an Apache
server, well,
that will work too.
So that's what I really like--
Flask.
Check it out.
If you haven't checked it out,
and you use Python at all-- if
you use Python at all, of
course, you would have checked
it out already.
If you haven't, and you're
getting into
that, check it out.
It's like almost the
anti-Django.
It's like a light, useful,
flexible framework, whereas
Django is a less light
framework.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, I mean in our
sample, we were really trying
to get it down as narrow as
possible and make it as easy
for developers to use.
And it's good to hear that you
agree with some of the choices
that we made.
And you're on the Drive API,
so you probably have done
these integrations before
between the Sign-in
solution and Drive.
So do you have any suggestions
for developers?
And what would they do to
get Drive integrated?
And then what would be something
cool that someone
could do after integrating
with Drive?
ALI AFSHAR: So we have
Drive quick-starts,
as well, very similar.
The Python one is
very similar.
We actually don't need a web
server to use the Drive API.
So we just have a command line
application, so it's
easier in that way.
Integrating + Sign-in
is very easy.
You go through, and you
add the Drive Scope--
that's an OAuth 2 scope.
And you add that scope, and
then immediately, you can
start making requests
to the Drive API.
It's beautiful, because the
scopes you request when you do
authorize the user, those
are all union together.
So I can then get a client, an
authorized HTTP client that
can make requests against the
Drive API and make requests
against the + API, and make
requests against any of our
APIs, really.
You just have to
ask for access.
So that's really, really nice.
What our quick-starts do is
we just upload a file.
So in your use case, I think the
most simple functionality,
and you've done that really
well, is just to find out who
the user is or find out
their friends or
something like that.
Our quick-start, we just upload
a file, so you select a
file and you upload it, pretty
simple, but get on.
So one extra thing I just wanted
to talk about was your
use of Virtual Environment.
Now I'm really, really
happy to see that.
And since you brought me on to
talk about Python, I guess I
should just bash my stick a bit,
which is when you run a
Python sample, or when you
install a Python sample,
always use Virtual
Environment.
Why?
Because you don't
want to actually
use your system Python.
The system Python is there
for the system to run.
And we're well past the days
when a Ubuntu system or a Mac
system wouldn't actually
need Python installed.
But now these systems use
Python, and they use them, in
depth, for lots of core
functionality.
So when you're installing
something using pseudo-pip
install, you have the ability to
really overwrite something
that the system is using and
something that is critical for
the function of your computer.
You don't want to do that.
So my takeaway for this is if
you have to run pseudo-pip
anything, you're probably
doing something wrong.
So check out Virtual Env.
Obviously, check out pip.
Pip and Virtual Env are written
by the same guy,
originally.
So they integrate
very, very well.
One will install the other.
So that's my tip to takeaway.
Always use a virtual
environment.
And thanks for doing that,
because that's
made me very happy.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, OK, good.
Well, I'm glad to have
made you happy, Ali.
Do you have any questions
for me about Google+?
ALI AFSHAR: So tell me--
I've seen it a bit.
I've seen your API a bit.
So just in a few lines,
tell me why + Sign-in?
Why is that good for me?
Why is that good for
my applications?
GUS CLASS: Yeah, well, one of
the key things that we're
doing in the sample is getting
that client authorized as well
as the server, so you can
then, using the Google+
Sign-in API, by connecting your
account with Google, what
you're doing is you're
authorizing the client on
JavaScript, and you're
authorizing the server.
So then you can do all of those
operations that you want
to do client side, as
well as server side.
And because of the way that the
client libraries work, you
can then, as you said, request
all the scopes that you want
and then get access to the
entire suite of functionality
that is available through
the Google platforms.
So this is a really powerful
tool for developers to get
their users integrating Google
functionality with their
actual third party sites.
ALI AFSHAR: That's cool.
So I get authorization and I get
authentication, as well?
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, awesome,
great.
So I'm a real fan.
It's something I've been using
in my pet projects.
It's just so much easier to just
put a bit of HTML on a
page and then sign-in auth
is just solved for me.
So I love that, so
thanks very much.
Keep that up.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, for sure.
And yeah, so that's pretty
much it for the Python
quick-start.
Inside of that quick-start,
what's happening is that the
client's authorizing, it's
passing an authorization code
to the server.
And then the server's
authorizing, so then both are
authorized.
And then some of the API calls
are performed on the client,
most notably the profile
retrieval.
And then some of the APIs are
performed on the server, which
is that Circles, the
people list.
And so the sample just
highlights those two steps for
using the Google+ API.
ALI AFSHAR: So yeah, it was
three minutes to go through.
But I think you can easily spend
a few hours picking the
bits out that are useful to
you for your application.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, it's really
worth mentioning that you can
go to the Google APIs Explorer
to see the scope of what you
can do with the APIs and
experiment with those
particular API calls.
So this is a great pro tip.
If you go to
code.google.com/apis/explorer,
you can explore the APIs and
experiment with what's there.
So that's a really great place
to explore what you can do
after you've got that
sample going.
So that's pretty much what
we have for today.
There's a couple of
announcements before we close.
The first is that now the People
Search API will allow
you to search for a Google+
user by email.
And the next is that there has
been a recent update to the
Android Google Play services
libraries that improves the
experience for sharing and
signing in on Android.
So for those really astute
Google+ Developers out there,
make sure that you check
out the new platform
functionality.
And feel free to ask us
questions in the Google+
Developers community.
And if you're looking for the
Google+ Developers resources,
the top ones will always
be listed at
developers.google.com/plus.
So thanks for watching, and
come back next week for
another Google+ Developers
Live.
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks.
[SWOOSHING]